i was lucky enough to actually host
um an hbo panel where you and i
in-depthly spoke
about your process in the undoing and i
was wondering if you would tell us about
how you treated this character
in defining the
multi-facets of him i do remember that i
felt i was playing two characters
and that they were both real obviously
the most real
was guilty jonathan who was a sociopath
um narcissistic sociopath who
only really loved himself and
couldn't love anyone else couldn't feel
for anyone else and
who is capable of killing without
feeling the the even a
smidgen of remorse but there was also
innocent jonathan
the jonathan who presented himself to
the world and he wasn't exactly a lie
because um jonathan had convinced
himself that that was
really the real him and that it was not
even conceivable
that this great doctor this great healer
of children this wonderful
father this wonderful husband this
charming man about
manhattan could possibly be a killer so
all those five and a half episodes i
spend in that series
saying i'm i'm i didn't kill her i
didn't kill her i may have been a little
unfaithful but i didn't kill her and i
love you
he believes all that and it was very
important that he he does believe it
because
you know all the evidence points pointed
to my guilt and to preserve the whodunit
aspect of that series i needed to be
convincing when i was
denying my guilt i love it and as true
sociopathic narcissist if you've studied
them
that is the exact behavior they do
they believe their lies they create
their own narrative and their and it's
infallible and
the only thing that snowballs for them
is
further um truth actually
upon the lies so you can't even peel
back the layers
to get to the truth that you just get so
far and it's just
happens to be a character trait um i
studied uh profusely and i was just so
blind
which boyfriend or husband was like that
um
i'll tell you we're not the cameras
aren't rolling but yeah i'm listen i
know
and and also you know there's a huge
amount that goes in the political game
of sociopathic narcissism
it falls into gaslighting there's an
extraordinary amount of behavior that
occurs
from one human being in a position of
power
or a family member that
does put on a charade that puts other
people in a washing machine
and it's a very different but for me the
common denominator in all those people
is is narcissism it's incredible
self-love
and you see it a lot in show business uh
but you see it a lot in politics which
of course some people
say is show business for the ugly and
[Laughter]
i've never heard that one before but
i'll never forget it
well hubert
i just thank my lucky stars that i get
to know you
um and that i still know you and i'm so
happy
for your family and your life and just
everything that you've
given to us and i love that you're sassy
and curmudgeony
and just send hubert kisses off into the
air
to you and your five beautiful children
and and your sexy
mean which you need probably beautiful
wife
[Applause]
yeah well i it was lovely to see you
drew
i'll see you in the um uh what was it
called the waverly inn
i'll meet you at the waverly and baby
hbo's original series the undoing is
streaming now on
hbo max